I was just coming to see you wait is it
because I'm gonna be queen
we love you Hades you were by far one of
our favorite new characters in
descendants 3 we loved your duet with
mal and we still can't get over your
cool blue hair and badass outfit we're
so happy that you and now we're able to
patch things up so now that you're a
freak on will you be taking your
daughter to the underworld for a family
vacation you'd seriously love to see
that we all thought that mal had no clue
who her father was
but we now know that's far from the
truth mal in Hades relationship has a
few loose ends we want to tie up watch
until the end to find out the truth
about Hades and mouths relationship who
is mouth father that's the question
that's been on everyone's mind ever
since the first descendants film aired
in 2015 it was thought that mal had no
idea who her dad was but that turned out
to be a lie in the under-the-sea trailer
Mao stumbles across a blue orb in a
forest and believes it to be her dad so
it's safe to assume that mal has known
who her dad was for many years now in
descendants 3-mile in Hades seeing an
amazing duet that gives us an inside
scoop on their relationship a tease is
convinced that he did malice solid by
taking himself out of the picture
he says her daddy issues have made her
stronger and that she was better off
without him but there's one line that
proves just how much he cares about his
daughter
he tells mal to pay him some respect
because it's not easy to neglect so this
means that abandoning mouth wasn't an
easy thing for him to do but that wasn't
enough to convince mal who still
couldn't forgive him from walking out on
her to find out who her real father was
Mao must have used the process of
elimination
and since Maleficent is one of the most
powerful villains of all time it makes
sense that she would fall for someone
equally as powerful as her if not more
at some point or another mouth figured
it out and she thought that Hades didn't
care about her but something changes
after the do what you gotta do do it see
tells mal something that changes the way
she sees her dad forever after finding
out that Edie's is mouths dad
Celia says so I guess that's the reason
why he's always asking about you hearing
this helps mal forgive Hades after all
he was secretly checking up on her from
afar it's also possible that mal asked
around the aisle and found out that her
mother and Hades used to be a thing it
isn't the first time Maleficent in Hades
have been coupled together in the Disney
verse back in 2003 Hades and Maleficent
were shown going on a date during a
house of mouse episode titled Halloween
with Hades so there was a paper trail
for mal de follow although it might look
like Hades wants nothing to do with
anybody in descendants three it's
actually hinted that Hades owns a
souvlaki restaurant in descendants -
there's a sign that says Hades of Lackey
it's under this world hung up right next
to the curl up and die salon so Hades
and mal might have crossed paths many
times over the years and who knows maybe
he gave mal a free gyro or two which
could have tipped her off quite a show
you put on the other day right back
atcha
Hades wasn't there for mal when she was
growing up but he's here for her now
sure he did abandon her as a baby and
attack her with his Ember for some
unknown reason but he's still a million
times better than Maleficent when it
comes to Maleficent and Hades Hades is
clearly the better parent yes he may be
a little wicked but he's nowhere near as
criminally insane as Maleficent
Maleficent didn't care about Mouse
feelings at all so we're team Hades from
here on out in Mallen Hades duet Hades
asks mal if she'll take him to auradon
for some father-daughter bonding time
but she's just not interested all mal
once is the ember it is a hate word on
in every
it stands for but he wants to make
things right with his daughter so he
gives her his most prized possession if
that's not saying sorry you don't know
what is
when mal walked out of his den Hades
whispered that's my girl which shows us
just how proud of her he is Mau always
wanted to make her mother proud but
nothing she did was ever evil enough so
it's nice to know that Hades has been
proudly watching his daughter from afar
since the very beginning
I guess reason why he's always asking
back sure that hades road to forgiveness
didn't stop there
when mal returned to the Isle and asked
her dad to save Audrey he did so without
a question
despite being past the barrier Hades
didn't try to escape the second he got
his hands on the Ember
instead he saved Audrey's life and
returned to the Isle but not before
doing something totally sweet and
selfless Hades gave his ember to mal
before being taken away by the guards
this touching moment was enough to make
anyone tear up by the end of descendants
three it's clear that mal has forgiven
her dad for leaving she hugged Hades and
welcomes him to auradon with open arms
mal in Hades are definitely going to
have an amazing relationship they'll
walk her down the aisle when she marries
Ben and he'll take her on a family trip
to the underworld whenever she's willing
we loved this song do what you got to do
which song from d3 was your favorite
tell us in the comments section and
that's a wrap give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time on the themes
[Music]
[Music]